watching you tube video what's up today
we speak english because the
international data corp ja leute was
geht
herzlich willkommen ich habe wieder hier
mein mit meiner frisur bin ich heute
unzufrieden ich habe wieder meinem handy
heraus gekramt weil ich weiß nicht das
haar und deshalb glaube ich auch nicht
so nice wir sitzen hier gerade um wie
spät es ist zwei uhr morgens also
eigentlich wollte schon vor 3 stunden
anfangen aber es hat einfach nicht
hingehauen
wir hatten kein licht des lichtes
ausgefallen weswegen wir das jetzt erst
machen können ja und ich gebe mal das
mikrofon weiter dann kannst du mir mal
erklären worum es geht ja gerne erklären
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ach so das war's schon von dir bleiben
beitrag
ach so also was man auch auf jeden fall
sagen muss ich habe auch noch nie auf
einem kanal gegen die was mit alkohol
gemacht also man muss aber sagen wir
haben schon ein bisschen was getrunken
heute normalerweise sind wir alle nicht
wirklich am trinken aber wir haben
salz stammt okay okay also ich sag mal
so wir sitzen hier schon seit drei
stunden haben das ein oder andere glas
wein getrunken weswegen wir damit heute
auch ford von wollen also wir machen so
eine kleine party
borussia dortmund hat auf dem
youtube-kanal ein video hochgeladen wo
jeweils zwei leute immer gegeneinander
angetreten sind und so machen wir das
heute auf die anfragen vorbereitet ihr
seid ein team you want you want ihm und
ihr habt die möglichkeit uns die fragen
zu stellen zum beispiel also zum
beispiel ihr stellt uns die frage wir
sitzen gleich zu rücken an rücken oder
einiges egal fällt mir grad auf wir
sitzen trotzdem rückgang rücken und
eltern die frage zum beispiel wer sitzt
mehr am tag am smartphone und wir müssen
dann auf 321 den namen sagen und wenn
wir den gleichen namen sagen haben
[Musik]
das haben wir auch noch als extra wegen
wenn man falsch liegt dann also wenn man
den unterschiedlichen namen sagt dann
muss man noch einen schluck wein trinken
genau dann würde ich sagen ihr habt
wahrscheinlich verstanden
tut mir leid für die schlechte qualität
heute aber es wird trotzdem durch lustig
also ich würde sagen der gast muss
anfang deswegen müsst ihr anfangen also
jeder von uns hat sechs fragen
vorbereitet und wer davon halte richtig
liegt also den gleichen namen sagt
dessen also dieses paar hat dann halt
gewonnen okay was öfters it right here
also ich hoffe ihr seid bereit ich bin
der quizmaster heute und ich stelle euch
die frage ob ich habe keinen akku mehr
scheiße hier sind die fragen drauf oder
priester down also ich bin heute jetzt
hier erst mal in der ersten runde der
quizmaster die ersten teilnehmer sitzen
schon auf ihren stühlen
das heißt wir haben jetzt jeder sechs
tragen wenn ihr mehr über einstellen
beantworten können habt ihr gewonnen
wenn wir mehr dann haben logischerweise
wir gewonnen hast du alles verstanden
ich muss bei denen alles auf englisch
leider
fragen weil er aus england kommt group
uk single countdown
okay okay was noch nie seine macs am tag
musiker of you have it more different
countries okay let's go
[Musik]
michael matthews band more time coaching
on your smartphone wer von euch
verbringt mehr zeit am handy mein
englisch ist neunter bester marie sorry
for that
watching you tube videos in youtube
[Musik]
videos schotthock des youtube und nach
hinzu die und schießt watching
youtube.com user von youtube ja okay
also dort jetzt wird doch jetzt viel ob
sie dass da mehr durch also war wie bis
bereich jetzt will ich auch wieder
enttäuschungen erste frage der würde er
komplett nackt durch die straßen laufen
123 also würde ich es nicht tun aber
eher als marie sogar an komplex ist de
ein porno drehen darunter 23 ja also ich
weiß dass mich der beste deswegen ich
bin jetzt nicht also ich sowas würde ich
auch nie tun damals aber da war seine
fahrt
also ich finde das jetzt eigentlich auch
nicht so schlimm um ehrlich zu sein aber
ich könnte nicht machen weil ich dann
ich weiß aber auch so wie meine freunde
und so also das geht nicht so weit freut
sich auf apples website europe
uk the most famous vorn hat ist klar
ok also wenn man schon zwei punkte also
wird ein kinderspiel sondern eine
schwierige frage und er will ja mit nur
5 euro auskommen
für ein ganzes jahr ein ganzes jahr
also alles wie könnte nicht mal selbst
wenn marie auf ihrem konto - 3000 euro
hätte würde ich gegen mein land außer
zweifel
so willkommen zu vielen fragen die
musste jetzt schwer und muss jetzt was
habt ihr einen schon verloren wer würde
er den instagram bekannt
aber ja ja ja ich weiß nicht mal sagen
du bist auch mit trink- und england ja
ich würde mich jetzt schon über diesen
diese wies die nochmals trinken aber
also leute ich weiß es war sehr
chaotisch aber das war's von mit der
challenge wir haben gewonnen und
verloren nur in österreich die sowie
kabarett fans danke fürs zuschauen war
ich ganz lustig auch wenn das wirklich
glaube ich dass also aufnehmen kann als
das wirklich das peinlichste video bis
jetzt würde ich sagen so von ja auch
schon weil ich hab noch nirgendwo an
verhinderungen und noch nie irgendwas
ist fragen beantwortet deswegen hoffe es
hat euch gefallen dass doch noch oben da
schon gern wein vorbei verlinke alle
kanäle in der video beschreibung
wir bringen jetzt kann ich vielleicht
jetzt nochmal wechsel geben